show tunes today joe biden issued new
executive orders or royal proclamations
as we say in my cultural tradition
uh as a matter of fact it was one of the
complaints of you rebel colonials
against poor old george iii
that laws were getting vaporized by the
royal prerogative yet
ever since january the 20th in
neo-monarchical washington
we've had legislation by photo op
whoever's
waggling that moth eaten old sock puppet
maneuvers
joe into position they slide the
executive order under his nose he
signs and it's now the law of the land
he's doing it at a brisk clip
and today he turned to the big one for
many americans
quote unquote gun control
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake from what we're talking about
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution
is absolute i've no idea what that
really means an amendment is part of the
constitution
and the constitution is certainly
constitutionally
absolute at least until they can rustle
up a judge to rule that the constitution
is unconstitutional
which judicial decision should be coming
any day now probably from the ninth
circuit
in practical terms the measures include
restrictions
on pistol stabilizing braces which joe
biden claims
allow handguns to be used as high
accuracy
low recoil rifles and yet with
the easy concealability of a pistol
a new rule closing yet another supposed
loophole
on so-called ghost guns you can
assemble yourself ghost guns is one of
those new scary terms they've come up
with
a national red flag law allowing family
members
or law enforcement to go to court for a
suspension of an individual's
second amendment rights and a gun
control advocate as
head of the atf boy i cannot wait
to see the impact these moves have on
child
shootings in chicago every weekend
behind these
executive actions biden hinted at a
rather devious legal theory
today we're taking steps to confront not
just the gun crisis
but what is actually a public health
crisis
nothing nothing i'm about to recommend
in any way impinges on the second
amendment
in no way whatsoever an odd verbal tick
he's got there
the more he insists nothing he's doing
impinges on the second amendment
the more ammo sales go through the roof
but executive orders
on guns in the name of public health may
be a runner in the last year we've seen
massive restrictions
on freedom of movement freedom of
religion freedom of association
freedom to work freedom to leave your
home freedom to have your relatives
round for thanksgiving
freedom of speech as we'll discuss later
all in the name
of public health last summer our public
health officials excused the looting of
american cities
on the grounds that white privilege is a
public health crisis
given the woeful quality of our judges
it's not hard to imagine some nitwit
jurist
signing on to the idea that public
health trumps the right
to bear arms top shot champion
and gun rights activist chris cheng is
here
uh chris what do you make of what joe
biden
proposed today yeah what the president
proposed
he's basically talking out of both ends
where he's saying
that these executive orders will not
infringe on our second amendment rights
then he goes on to list
a whole number of infringements on our
second amendment rights
and so what is concerning and
frightening
is that all of these gun control
measures
are not going to do anything to improve
public safety
they're not going to do anything to
reduce mass shootings and really
we're still going to be uh we're still
going to have a
a huge problem on our hands uh with with
violence in our country
and so i'm very um uh disappointed but
not surprised
to see president biden to come out today
in support of uh
some pretty strong gun control measures
this this
ghost guns thing is just the later every
so often these guys come
up with a scary term uh and they want to
abolish ghost guns and ghost guns sound
sounds pretty scary uh but it's
basically just uh
hobbyists i mean i've got a neighbor of
mine who
likes to work and he's actually a
bleeding heart liberal but he like
actually likes to to work on guns uh
taking them apart putting them back
together as his hobby
uh that does absolutely nothing for the
uh
disgraceful uh epidemic of crime in
democrat-run cities does it
it absolutely does not and you know the
america has
a long tradition of citizens being able
to make firearms at home
at the end of the day firearms are
simply a mixture of
metal and plastic parts and so yeah the
term ghost gun is a completely made-up
political term that is uh supposed to
make us scared
right that that americans are are
somehow doing something new when in fact
this isn't anything new
um you know it's it's it's something
also that
we you can't really control what people
make in their own homes and so the idea
of the government
trying to restrict something that that
one can make in their own home it's
it's sort of one of these laws if they
even pass a law like how are you even
going to enforce it
but isn't that the problem with the red
flag thing too
that essentially i mean everybody knows
uh for example when you
you take a complaint to a court and a
policeman comes around
and confiscates your guns there's a lot
of kind of crude revenge in this
uh domestic uh people in divorce court
uh one files are complained against the
other the cop knocks on the door the
guns attack
red flag laws just make though uh the
a national red flag law would just make
that even looser
uh even more prone to just crude revenge
wouldn't it
yeah the problem with red flag laws is
right now it's
it is this patchwork of different state
regulations
and you know ultimately who is supposed
to be the trusted arbiter
of whether an individual is uh
you know of sound mind to retain their
second amendment rights
and so the proposals that the the
president's administration is
going to come forth with i'm pretty sure
is going to fall
short of the due process requirements
that that gun rights advocates such as
myself want to see to ensure that we're
making we're striking
some sort of balance between uh our
second amendment rights
and uh and mental health advocacy
and meanwhile all the bad guys will
still
be putting bullets into three-year-old
kids in chicago
caught in the crossfire because they
happen to be crossing the wrong
intersection a terrible situation thank
you for that chris
as i said joe's signing pen
which is presumably remote controlled by
susan rice the world economic forum in
davos george soros
the chinese polit bureau earned stavro
glofeld and specter take your pick
joe's signing pen is now a one-man
legislative branch but today's orders
are nevertheless
an expansion of its power uh gail
trotter is a
constitutional lawyer and gail what's
interesting to me well not actually
interesting to me about this is rather
scary uh but this is um
the extension of x of executive order
explicitly at one of the rights adam
rated in the bill of rights so a call
right
uh is it uh constitutionally uh
a bit iffy to you i'm so glad you
brought this
up mark and i'm so glad you're covering
this topic
because the supreme court held that the
second amendment guarantees an
individual right to possess firearms for
self-defense
and like you said unlike some of the
rights that the supreme court has
guaranteed individual rights some would
say have invented
this one is in the literal text of our
constitution of our bill of rights the
right to keep and bear arms
and there are only two other times in
the bill of rights
where the people are guaranteed an
individual right that's in the first
amendment
the right to assemble and petition the
government and in the fourth amendment
to be
secure against unreasonable searches and
seizures and you said at the beginning
of the show
our history with england and
understanding that we are
people under the rule of law and all the
things in our bill of rights like the
fact that the government cannot control
our speech the fact that the government
cannot tell us which religion
to profess this is what undergirds
all of those rights and without the
second amendment
you really have a situation where you
switch the balance of power from the
government
from the people to the government and
unfortunately
we all want to have a safer society but
the
these executive orders by the biden
administration
are just basically gun grabbing attempts
where they're going to take away gun
rights from the sane
and the law abiding and you're not going
to have any effect on the criminals who
are behind the violence
their their thinking though i take it is
this that if you were to say
uh we're done with the second amendment
it's over
and we're going to move to get rid of it
everyone goes nuts but they
figure don't they that they can nibble
away
at it bit by bit by bit and eventually
with enough executive orders
they'll only be like you know 47 to the
second amendment left
that's right you might remember the very
important supreme court decision heller
that was the case that really supported
this understanding of the second
amendment that it has an
individual right to possess firearms
that are typically held for
law abiding purposes and you might
remember the dissenting judge in that
case
wrote an opinion saying oh what's the
problem for people in d.c
because they're on a mere subway ride
away
they can go to a jurisdiction where they
can exercise their second amendment
rights
and fortunately the majority opinion in
that case
understood that it doesn't work to get
on a subway and coax a criminal to go
with you
to exercise your right to self-defense
in maryland
instead of dc so we have to make sure
that we
citizens insist on exercising our rights
because the supreme court only takes up
a few cases every year
they don't take up a lot of second
amendment cases so this
action should be opposed and you should
let the department of justice and the
white house
know that you understand what they're
doing exactly what you said mark they're
trying to chip
chip away at our fundamental second
amendment rights
and i certainly agree with what you said
about having to maintain them
in every jurisdiction uh it's not enough
for it to be in the neighboring state uh
as you were saying there uh great to see
you gail and uh
this is eventually i think gonna i know
john roberts is shy about taking a lot
of these controversial topics but i
think it will eventually
wind up before the high court thank you
gail